what's going on reject nation greg and
john here
we're gonna be doing a reaction today
for willy's wonderland
so excited to check this out we don't
really do movie reactions all that often
but for this
i was like hell yeah let's of course do
it for this one man this looks so cool
so by the time this is uploaded we
should have completed an interview with
the director
kevin lewis so guys please do go ahead
make sure to check it out you're about
to watch his reaction
highlights obviously cannot include the
full movie
over at our patreon we cover plenty of
tv shows where the same tier you get the
option for reaction highlights and watch
alongs included like a whole bunch of
these shows of thumbnails that i'm
flashing up on screen right now
hopefully you're able to read a couple
of titles and normally our full-length
reaction watch alongs where you sync up
with the time code or only
at our patreon page but for willy's
wonderland it's just in the description
box
if you own the movie or if you want to
rent it and watch along with us as
opposed to
doing the reaction highlights it's right
there in the description box available
for you guys
anywho that's the intro
[Music]
[Music]
oh no
[Laughter]
oh no a kid's responsible for everything
yes oh this movie's gonna be a blast
just look how hyperkinetic everything
already is
i love the pixel texture yeah all right
it's like an old school computer font
no
all that cool driving just to have your
tires blow out
his name like john drifter or something
it's gotta be
they've done so much character
development just with his boots in his
car
punch pop
cool he stood here all day
digesting his punch you know what some
folks consider funny
just one man's whole damn day god's
honest truth
oh you want those guys don't look back
i'm doing it past lives in the past
was terrible just wow
damn it's their claim to fame
hello
you [ __ ] don't you before the movie's
even begun
don't you dare burn it down open the
door of the damn door
you fix the damn door you all right
yeah he'll be all right tire's not but
he'll be fine
hello love interest he's about his age
yeah only a couple years on
i think i'm in love
or is there some hint to that history
between the two you're a [ __ ]
oh i love you too
it's her mom that's yup she's so great
for her old age
i was saying the the girl who tied up is
the mom i was trying to yes and you
oh cash only huh oh and in advance yeah
i don't take the
credit card oh no is that why he gets a
job
yeah we ain't got no internet in
hayesville it's like they want him to
work there absolutely
you willing to work it off
is what this town does
what is it what is he
i don't understand he seems like he's
enjoying himself i've got a guy for you
is that just a slim jim or is that an
actual like
cigar don't be racist ah of course
white guy welcome to willie's wonderland
yeah he don't talk much
and i respect that
of course you do you spend the night
cleaning willy's wonderland
i would love to have your car fixed you
come out of there
and you're right i'm ready for you
what a way to phrase it
[Music]
i feel like this is almost making fun of
a winding reffin movie
let's just do slow zooms and stairs
all right all right he hasn't talked
once no not once has he talked not once
not even so much as like a swallow
oh how cool damn these look great
which you gotta think for like an indie
movie that was those look
really great yeah the animatronics damn
it does look like like a legit kid's
playland
well some of these little bastards start
crawling over the characters they get
hurt
a couple of lawsuits later from mommy's
safety organization
shut us right down it's a good thing
this quiet guy
encounters people who love to just
expositionally monitor
you all the time
just fill me with your projections don't
even ask a question
just wait they'll do it people will tell
you what they want to tell you
you are officially on staff
don't put it on help yourself to
whatever you can find in the kitchen
it's on the house the [ __ ] would be in
the kitchen
[Laughter]
they got a lifetime's worth of frozen
pizza
i love the transitions
i think he'll make it think he'll make
it out alive
piece of [ __ ] all right let's get that
i can't stand to hear a grown man scream
why is he device trying to fix that
place
up have y'all never worn her handcuffs
before shut up just look for the key
what the hell am i looking in the fridge
for
that's me in this situation pliers or
something
unexpected you know she'd be the last
one you'd expect to figure it out but
she's the one who figured it out
what are the odds what are the uh
subverting expectations come on we're
late i saw the mate already oh
let's roll out wanna see that [ __ ] burn
yeah burn baby burn
wait guys
this isn't for your entertainment okay
it's for our entertainment
if we're doing this we're gonna do this
as a mission not a field trip
you're just taking all the fun out of it
aren't you jeez
whoa it all started
well the way that shot was done because
only one of them was in focus so then as
they all start to move they all start
becoming in focus
oh good eat some flour
he grunted dialogue pop
punch pop this is all i eat
put some punch pop in the oven
put it in the cleaning solution
[Music]
kitchen's the place for this don't be
misled
he's gonna start
but how much progress has he made is he
gonna be done by boarding
i'm glad nicholas cage has his own genre
now he's so much fun to watch
whoa ugh
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh don't know how unfazed he was with
you nobody makes me bleed my
blood oh
oh oh oh oh he got he's getting high off
of this nice
like a screamis texas yes yes
get him get him
oh my god
go don't stop go
how that serves as blood i went down
i knew what i was signing up
just gonna keep on cleaning i take it he
knew what was what the story was about
this place
either that or this isn't his first time
seeing something like this
you get a bit of a drifter ghost hunter
kind of vibe about him this is what andy
and toy story grows up to become
why'd you request the state to send back
up for one night i got a wife and
kid on the way and i do love the
overtime double overtime
gonna laugh at your dumb ass anyway
give me all this extra money we're gonna
sit here and pray it don't ring
so they only used like drifters to try
to clean up the place i guess i guess
yeah so they have this whole thing
mapped out with the atm and all that
there's a whole history and lore here to
be uncovered guys
we need to please the enemy watch like
40 ending explained videos
is this gonna blow my mind
damn dude you clean up good
and he hasn't taken one bathroom break
i would love it if he actually never
never speaks
that whole time i think that word that'd
be awesome
but if he does speak i'll also be just
as satisfied
because then it's just a matter of
what's he going to say and how
or maybe if he only like screams
oh no i love the graffiti all over this
movie
oh that looks like such a pain in the
ass yeah
and all that oh i shudder to think with
the toilets themselves look like oh
god damn we're probably gonna see it
yeah
cleaning montage but with a much darker
undertone
it's not the saw bathroom after all
kills it it just goes about his day
doesn't even need to clean it up and uh
you know if the rest of them come to
life i'll deal with that then
look how good his job he is you don't
need to be drifting man
i don't get why he just doesn't go and
kill all them they're all bound to come
to life what are the odds that more than
one of them are gonna come
yes
oh no they did not just wreck the
bathroom we spent forever cleaning
too far it's not a very good birthday
present
there's one line the movie should be i
just cleaned
up never find me
there's a stick there for you to use oh
where'd you see where did he come from
come on man only you yes
he actually punches it in the face
yes we do not deserve nicholas cage for
these things
oh yes
oh they've reversed the shot oh
no he has to clean the whole bathroom up
again
that's so cool how they could get away
with like nc17 violence just because
they're animatronics
that's so funny and they're using the
oil as blood i
love it i just like the oil doesn't
matter any less disturbs in this perfect
the trailer i thought it was bloody was
covered it
thought it was just get rid of just take
him on man
take him on
you wanna fight he curved stop that
gorilla
it's time for my pup it's like it's
medicine or something
just keeps going through the night
what's the secret of the pop
so the punch pop is merchandise now
right
it better be
he deserves a break and i like that he
worked this into the job incrementally
did they wait till night time or did it
just take them forever to get back there
you know it's a big small town
or they did this right at dusk
you guys are sadistic there's a good
hard-working man in there yeah and he's
doing a good job
and he needs his car fixed can you pour
gas literally anywhere else
i'm sorry you pour like crap there
you're pouring gas on top of them
that guy's still in there we got to get
him out first save the cat
this i like hits now
we're gonna burn we're gonna burn this
place down hey look if he don't want to
be safe
it's his ass not ours this is [ __ ]
psychopath kid he had his chance
look if he wants to burn down we're
gonna burn it here
burn his body to be responsible for
manslaughter whatever hurry to sit up so
we can go home hurry saving this damn
guy his
life already
he's alive it better not be i don't know
yeah please gender these animatronics
properly
oh that's the worst now
whoa save her
she's the only one who doesn't want to
burn you alive i know
it's gotta count for something
oh oh
i love the drool too i didn't even know
you smoked
how would you get this well i grew it
myself i call it no clue
what i'm cold
what is that character of that girl
it's so funny
yo this should not be at your local
chuck e cheese i'll tell you that much
unless this is like their little home
that they've created themselves
hey i've waited
oh
[Music]
[Music]
cool
[Music]
some great lens choices in this movie
[Music]
no no i actually want to leave and i
thought y'all might want to also but i
don't care
i'm fine i'll go no no i'll go no wait
you stop
i'll go
[Laughter]
hey
don't look at her ass i'm trying to
commit arson and double man
it doesn't give you license to creep
oh did you not hear what i just said
hey maybe he's one of the animatronics
that
developed a sentient form like a human
flesh form he evolved
yeah and now he's killing the evidence
[Laughter]
and now we probably all getting [ __ ]
up because of him bobby what
am i lying no i'm not it's the truth
i love her i do too she's so funny
slobby
oh no
good thing there were that was those
there the ball yeah this is a very
strategic pulpit
we're here to rescue all of us we all
agreed unanimously
oh no
it just runs right for it yeah no
what are you doing what the hell man
what are you doing
we are those looks say a lot
stop stop
oh what happened to you dude
they've said the same story to countless
other over the last 20 years
i know i was here 15 years ago i was the
first
brainchild of jerry robert willis jerry
was one of the last century's
most sick and sadistic serial killers oh
you're the most depraved people you
could ever imagine
ugh to the super happy fun room oh no
oh damn
gary and his crew had performed a
satanic suicide ritual
transfer energy the memory and
consciousness of the living
relocate into non-living entities like
chucky
like the soda pop like the soda
he tries to keep the current public
unaware of its horrendous just get rid
of the
animatronics it's a perfectly usable
space
jurors would move on their own some
would say
things they weren't programmed to say
still doesn't bulldoze it to the ground
why you may ask
where'd bob and kathy go
being stupid i love how he fought to not
go in here and
now they're in here they can walk right
up to the animatronics and go sneak off
at the super happy fun room where they
probably know the lore i was like
probably know the history
they might yeah they do
cool oh she's into it
true crime is is very popular these days
oh she's into it does she have something
to do with this
she may be maybe she's possessed are you
really turned on right now
no no no i'm going right now yeah let's
do it oh you were freak freak
oh you both are going to get killed
right now have you been listening to a
word i've been saying
i memorized this whole speech and
everything
[Music]
why are you guys getting closer to them
[Music]
uh-oh
damn oh that's not
gonna end well whoa whoa you're lucky
yeah
he's like ooh i'm okay you may get
through this
dude you must be so bloated
[Laughter]
he looks like he's he's about to
fornicate with that
thing oh he's by himself he's by himself
no
oh good it's just an inflatable
chris go to the the blinking light room
here i know
you go by yourself run you'll be safe
for theirs
i'm just gonna hide there all day
oh no no
[Music]
dang
they do seem to move like spiritual like
supernatural
yeah yeah just up here and reappear put
your balls on evan
we're going to put your balls on
they're just taunting him yeah they're
playing with their food
[Music]
ugh oh no
[Music]
why are you ignoring it
just needed a break i guess you just
need to recharge
yeah there are some great shots of
kinetic it is yeah
oh
you're trying to save my life
bobby that thing just moved where the
[ __ ] did it go
oh yeah
oh
are you still turned on
oh he's like way dead he's dead yeah for
a second i was like you can do it man
yes no okay oh they're both
super dead
look at all this he has to clean up
yes yes yes
rip it out dude
[Applause]
come come on
[Music]
don't be stupid man come on don't be
stupid don't be stupid
no i'm chris trust me chris
you know you can't no you don't i doubt
we'll need to drop them
it's not the kids it's willy
nice try so cool they got demi james
stars
i can't wait to see him redo the kill
count machines got out
we found the ice cream shop the hardware
store
what oh my god we got a deal
leave our town be and we will feed you
[Music]
oh oh no
tried to find people who wouldn't be
missed
oh wow wow wow
sometimes oh she's adopted
oh dang oh chris
live it's gonna be okay okay we're gonna
make a deal oh
no damn you
oh
oh no
what is it it's a weird routine yes i
gotta get in the zone
with pinball and punch
oh is it working
no try to get her to get her tongue out
and cut that
oh he got it
is he is he saying something oh he's
just going oh
like an arcade
hallway fight hallway fight one shot
hallway fight
i love how no one can take these down
until he showed up
drop the lizard
what is this willie i'm so sorry about
this prick
oh damn lady no way i'm not leaving him
here
i'll give you two reasons why you are
your wife
and your kid what he's not trapped in
here with them
fear trapping with him not for much
longer
she does have a point
oh he can still take him on with his
hands behind his back
maybe he survived willie's wonderland as
a child
what the [ __ ] what what
i said things right that's what i'm god
damn gonna do you
oh no no no
what
leave him leave him
[Music]
damn
get back to cleaning
now
finish him finish him
why aren't you driving you just find the
keys
there's keys you didn't like tossing
that far
[Laughter]
[Music]
too much trauma to drive the car now
he's dead
what if he runs out of shirts
he's still bleeding still dedicated to
this
it's like an ocd guy even though he
knows the truth
even though [ __ ] all of these characters
for being murderous monsters
like he knows that none of this is about
paying him to get his car back
and they just take them over they are
the ones who blew out his tires yeah
they're not gonna replace anything like
i'm gonna clean
i just wanna see their faces tomorrow
morning when the job is done
then noah centennial could play him in
the prequel oh
perfect it's origins
come on willy yeah see what you're made
of so far it's been no problem for this
guy
yeah and you've been sitting here just
letting your henchmen do all the work
better hope he doesn't drink another
soda
it's like you make the first move [ __ ]
i do not understand this this is just
how this man gets in the zone
a few chances in a drifter's life to
really just be yourself
and unload i want i want this pinball
[Music]
machine
[Music]
[Laughter]
what's that goddamn son of a [ __ ]
inside now just give him a chance what's
the worst that could happen
we had a good thing but you just [ __ ]
it all up
oh well he's not there well he needs to
eat
and i'm gonna feed him well hey wouldn't
you love to be rid of this
oh he gonna take you out
damn whoa
oh oh [ __ ]
that was nuts that was
nuts oh jesus it's just an oh my god
whoa one shot
sprayed out like animatronics too
she is the big boss
no
oh willie have you underestimated him
and i'm gonna keep my supply with me
i thought he's gonna use his like hit
him with it he could either one has a
plausible choice
but i think he's gonna use it to swing
at him
oh what a icky shot so stretched out
oh it's like a storage and a ball chain
yeah yeah yeah
like a sword and a mace oh
get him come on you can do it
this is so ridiculous
[Music]
oh my gosh
oh damn willy
[Music]
rip its life force out oh
yeah come on
[Music]
yes yes yes
now where are the heads like a necklace
yes
this is the biggest are they [ __ ]
around this car
oh no oh damn
[Laughter]
i was already thinking it was shot like
a like a rob zombie like a wrong song
sup [ __ ]
hand it over
yeah you guys probably can't hear the
song the reaction highlights by the way
absolutely not just to be visible on
youtube
but what about what about creepy creepy
oh she's oh she's she's gonna be his
daughter now she's gonna have a whole
lot of conversations
that's right now drive angry you ghost
rider
on down the road to another face-off
there's one tough on break meet your
demise now
oh my god it's actually over
we're gonna celebrate i'm buying foul
good it's our lucky day
oh jesus christ
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
the janitor janitor
i like these star-studded critics
i miss chuck e cheese well they're
probably going to open them back up soon
right
it's one of my favorite places to go
check your cheese man 25 cents tokens
25 cents arcade which is 25 cents token
muy bueno yeah that's spanish with
italian gestures
you were the first person to ever take
me to a chuck e cheese believe it or not
i won't be the last she will not be the
last of my videos
oh this is the willy's wonderland song
it's a good song it convinced me that it
was like an
already existed yeah
it's really well done props to the
special effects people too
some good oh yeah amatrox are great
they're fantastic
they're like legit good every time
they're on screen like yeah these are
great
blood gags and stuff they don't just
look gags the way not just the way they
look but the way they move
yeah and they're all unique specific
movements that's fun that was a blast
you know sometimes sometimes you know if
i watch a movie
i'm normally like laying down on my
couch or i'm moving around i might walk
around a little bit i'm not one who
actually
remains still on the couch you know or
at the theaters
or the theaters i'm a very annoying
person to tend to move me with
i'll be pacing around facing around
putting my feet up on the member's
chair in front of me you know it's like
i'll probably switch chairs to the
bridge so i'm checking my phone
taking text you know what's going on on
collider.com just doing a whole bunch of
things
but no i mean like to sit in these
chairs they thought of like sitting here
for
85 minutes it's like i'm probably going
to want to move around
mm-hmm but that flew by yeah this
really flew by it was very easy to pay
attention to
it doesn't require the most like brain
work but yeah but it stays
entertaining yeah it's easy to get lost
in then to the point that you're not
thinking about the time you're just
happy to keep going with it yeah yeah
man that was a really fun movie
it gave me everything i wanted honestly
like this this had actually the perfect
rhythm
and line to me that it wrote because it
could have been one of two things it
could have gone out there
far too much where it could have reached
into and now it's just annoying
yeah to the point where it's like i can
tell how clever you think you are or how
cute you think you're being
yeah or it could have just gotten so
kinetic all the time
yeah that it would have been so
frustrating to sit through it absolutely
it could have been very one note
yes or it could have been the exact
opposite where it's like you didn't go
far enough yeah now you're kind of bored
why did you squander this
magnificent opportunity yeah you could
it could have gone the complete opposite
direction where you're like well now
this is kind of
tedious and boring to sit through
because you could have gone further with
your
expressionism of all this yeah and i
thought for the most part like there's a
few things that i would have been like i
would have wanted a little bit more of
this on like an actual film level yeah
but i gotta say in terms of the mood
and rhythm and tone it struck and the
energy
i thought it was the right level through
like i'd say
95 of it i thought it was the right
pitch films like this can easily sway
kind of boring or too much and this i
thought actually hit the right note
and i'll say it too like you got to give
nick cage credit absolutely
the guy doesn't say one line in here the
entire time no it's all grunts
and it's not easy to make a character
like this
appealing to watch when they don't talk
the entire movie
it's not easy there's very few people
who can do it
and i think it's interesting too because
so much of nicholas cage's
larger-than-life persona has got to do
with his voice and his inflection and
the way he's
over the top expressions yeah and and
watching even the trailer for this i was
like okay well i was really into like
say mandy so this looks like a perfect
thing to be in line with that but even
in that movie like he's got a lot of
dialogue and things like that it was
weird it's like this is the kind of
badass b
movie nicholas cage character
performance you would want but yeah that
added element of no dialogue at all
actually enhanced it for me and made it
feel more than just
a nicholas cage meme even though it is
nicholas cage meme i'm still like going
damn this is
impressive that yeah like he's not
really speaking and yet still he's got
all this presence yeah
and he is sort of anchoring with this
weird gravity
you know the movie yeah and there's they
keep the thing mysterious about him the
whole time yeah
i love that yeah i actually got the
opposite of what i thought we'd get
where
we might get nick cage backstory but not
much on willy's but not much on willy
but then you actually have this
whole lore that is unveiled about not
just willie's wonderland but its effect
on the town
with the sheriff and the deal they make
with all that
i thought that was smart too because i
feel like at the outset you know
this movie could have just gone what's
going on some weird's going on at
willy's right but they they really know
that we know that that's gonna be the
case and i like that they
applied that to the story yeah i thought
the structure of it was actually
differently executed than i anticipated
on
all accounts yeah i thought it would
have been like okay you're gonna watch
him clean up for
a while he's gonna go about his time
even when they were setting it up with
him being there i thought he'd be
cleaning for a while
and then one thing would break out and
then eventually just kind of be non-stop
until cop showed up blah blah blah
so actually you get more richness
through the fact that the town is
involved in the human sacrifice element
and i love the the way they toy with the
janitor character
of he's cleaning gets to a fight murders
one of them viciously
all right let's get back to cleaning and
i'm like what is
happening but you settle into this guy's
just got some ocd patterns
his buddy yeah he's like he's got very
specific rituals and when he commits to
something
he's going to see it through you feel
like there's a depth to the guy it's not
just nicholas cage
there's a land here where you can chalk
up what nick cage is doing as to yeah
there's nick cage being nick cage and
walking through scenes well i don't
think that's the case
i felt like there's a whole detail with
his background here it felt like he
built a character and played it
yeah because whenever something threw
him off his groove
yeah he played into that yeah yeah it
was like
those like weird twitches that he would
do and then he seemed to
and the more he took the pop and the
more he played the pinball the more
extreme his expression became
loose he became yeah it felt like that
was all very intentional yeah this is
just like yeah this weird
silent character development over the
course of the movie through body
language
yeah it was it they had it all play out
differently than i thought
i mean the kids are all like stupid man
yeah
you know i mean they're they're a lot of
familiar characters but i thought
everybody did a nice job at least
in bringing life to them i mean like the
sheriff and the deputy are
more so actual characters than the kids
are
safe for uh you know the the main girl
uh yeah the main girl's a little bit
more of a character
i enjoyed the weird
sexual bubble pop girl
strangely air-headed but also like
is she on a whole other plane or
something yeah she's got yeah she played
this note i couldn't identify with that
very much tickled me throughout
i mean they were the one part like
especially with the guy who was dating
her or the guy who was at least banging
her
their logic as ludicrous as this film is
as ridiculous as this whole
concept is that part did pull me out a
little bit of just
wait a minute you guys know what this
guy just seems so inconsistent in his
choices
and that was the one thing is like as as
heightened
and silly as a lot of this is everything
did feel very committed
to its characters at the end of the day
yeah with its sheriff
with texts with the guy who picks them
up when after slashing the tires
nick cage the daughter who is out to
burn this place down like that was the
one part of this or i'm like oh now it
just feels like a stupid slasher movie
yeah yeah if i had maybe cared just a
little more or if you guys had maybe
demonstrated
a little bit more soundness of mine i
might have cared a little bit more
instead of just being like yeah let's
let's do some carnage
yeah i think they could have still
landed them in the death spots they
needed to be
absolutely and had them be a little bit
more clicked into the situation they've
been talking about this whole time
yeah because they actually felt kind of
separate tonally from the rest of the
movie that
i think that's what it is yeah that's
fair obviously we're reviewing this
immediately after reacting to it so
sometimes we'll
come to the thought process properly
later
but that was the thing is everything
felt tonally on the same page
and at the right height and level and
then this part was like i just like
slash free kids to kill off or idiots
yeah um
and and to that degree too i think there
could have also been
better opportunity if you know those
characters had been
a little more tailored to the situation
for nick cage to interact with them too
yeah but i'll say like they weren't that
big of a deterrent as much as i'm making
it out to be
like yeah they weren't actually like a
lot of what they brought in
a lot of their scenes were still pretty
amusing to watch you know i was never
like i'm annoyed get out of this movie
you don't belong here
you know so i i will say that in terms
of the tone too with their characters i
thought they were on the same page as
well there's a certain kind of energy
you got to hit with your performance in
a movie like this and i thought they all
were directed in the right way of where
to go yeah
the animatronic scenes i thought were
great obviously i cannot talk about them
i thought they were like
built so well yeah and i love how they
were all given specific
movements i would have liked to have
seen like i liked when they mixed up
their personalities a lot more
yeah weirdly willie's the one who i
thought had the least personality
because we didn't really get like a we
got like a fight with willie and we get
the whole backstory surrounding him but
as
the animatronic yeah he kind of has the
least juicy in terms of just like
playing with nick cage or whoever yeah
they like build them up to be the big
baddie which he did kind of feel like at
one point he felt like that boss level
in a video game that you played for two
hours and you're breezing through it
then you get to this boss and you're
like why is this
pain in my ass i want to go to bed i
don't want to stop now
but i can't stop until i beat him you
know like they felt like that level of
boss yeah
because i loved how mysterious they were
keeping willy throughout mm-hmm
like the character with the tongue yeah
i love that
yeah of the manipulation tactic of i'm
different from all of them i'm here to
confide
show you what the other side is just an
unfortunate soul trapped amongst the
serial killers i thought that was cool
uh the gorilla personality actually
embodying the gorilla you know
that's cool even spanish guy spanish guy
and then you know you got the drooling
alligator who's just you know just
popping up in
vents in places but it's still like i'm
a chopper
yeah yeah it's got the drool and all
that and even a creepy lady who uh
sets him on fire yeah i loved her uh
with her nasty mouth
because this movie could have been
annoying with you get very kinetic with
your shots that are not
action shots and i like how that was
reserved
for the action it's like caffeine vision
yeah
it was it was like they would turn into
cranks it up like like
like crank yeah it gets kinetic in
those scenes and you really feel that
with when like nick cage is handcuffed
he's look he's staring them down and
they just are shaking his head in the
camera so it's getting kinetic the
kinetic energy is tied in with that
it's through his perspective it almost
feels like versus
just every scene being that way which
could have been very
frustrating yeah i thought they i found
myself thinking part way through that
like oh it seems like they actually have
a better
grip than i would have even necessarily
expected on when to slow the tone down
when to go back to something a little
more normal a little bit light because
yeah you do expect especially from the
trailer to have just
a ton of chaos and i think it would be
very easy to just succumb to that and
make it just one
big kinetic fest and i think that they
did nicely throughout to
know when to shift the focus a little
bit or cut to an outside scene or
something to give it a sort of dynamic
throughout
yeah i thought like they captured in the
mood of the janitor
that's what i thought most of this was
captured yeah and i i thought that was a
really clever
touch to have to it of like no we'll let
the way we're directing all this be
in the reflection of and scripted too
because i like the script it's funny
it's a fun script yeah like everyone
just shows up and monologues the [ __ ]
out of nicholas to nicholas page
he's not even asking a single question
it's set up in a way where i'm like i
can tell some of these
are like strategic info dumps but in a
way that almost feels like they know
and they're using yeah the the b b-movie
fun and the characters you know colorful
dialogue
to help make some added humor on top of
that yeah they they know
and i i think that's where the
self-awareness is really plays in
and that's why you can get away with it
in a movie like this yeah i do
think um something that was definitely
missing
for me as it kept going because the
first couple fights
uh no not a problem at all okay i
thought as it kept going though
it just seemed like he was able to just
take them all out like no problem like
then
most of them didn't put up much of a
fight you know yeah he barely got hurt
and even with willy like he gets slashed
and dash and then
he comes back comes back and then
doesn't say that yeah exactly you know
he just needed that extra oomph to be
like okay i gotta take out one more
yeah i felt like the stakes in the fight
could have been raised a little bit with
like
this has to be more of a struggle for
the janitor that's what was missing with
some of the struggle because there's so
much of those great shots
that seem to represent the struggle and
anguish and rage
getting covered in like the blood oil um
which is a nice touch i love
and i do love how in the fights they did
things that felt barbaric
to animatronic characters like the jaw
rip
the curb stomping the brutal face
mashing
all those things i i thought was a smart
way to get to get away with some of
these things that kind of
brought it to like an anime level yeah
you know it's like hyper
violent but it's still dementedly
childish in some way
yeah yeah i just wish there was some
some more struggle to it because the
fights are fun they're like they're just
so ridiculous it's like no fight yeah
it's like a video game
it's like he does the same maneuvers and
video like what is my video game
what's he capable of doing and he just
does those moves yeah
so i do think that yeah that has like
mortal kombat finishers
you know i i feel like if they had maybe
mixed in a certain level of like okay he
has to
figure some stuff out each time or as
they escalate you know he has to
i don't know get a little more clever
with how he sure approaches them or
something
like not that the movie begs that but if
it had i think that could have maybe
made it feel
that much more rewarding and cathartic
once you really get through
all of them because yeah it's like the
first ones have i think
the coolness and and harshness of the
just finishing moves to really
seal that impact and then as the movie
goes on and more things are happening i
feel like yeah if we maybe had him
at least have to like break a sweat a
little bit to figure out what to do that
could have helped it didn't feel like it
escalatingly got more difficult for him
in fact it seemed like it got easier for
him
yeah there could have been maybe a
little bit more attention because i
didn't think the movie dragged much but
there are times
especially when it gets later where
you're like i kind of know he's going to
take care of this
yeah just it became that way yeah but
there was always fun that's the thing is
like even in those little tidbit moments
i like the sheriff actress a lot i don't
know her name beth grant i think
beth grant i think it's beth grant i
think it's the name displayed in front
of me on the computer right here right
now you know if she had
third billing and you know she's the
only other recognizable actress in the
movie
she doesn't look like an emily tosta
she's probably better probably beth
graham stands to reason
fact check us i liked her performance a
lot and i
i thought you know because they add the
willies wonderland lore and they spread
it out
it does make it more rich and it defied
the structure that a movie like this
normally would have gone down which is
the structure i
initially thought it was gonna be yeah
it's like what's the weird thing
happening at willy's and that's not
really what's developing it's like what
made it this way
why is it still this way yeah i love
like the tease of well just because he
destroyed the animatronics doesn't mean
the spirits aren't still around
yeah in some way you know and it also
showed that like even though he beheaded
some of them
some of them are still able to stand you
know yeah yeah yeah yeah i thought this
was a really fun movie emily toss it was
fun too
everyone was really fun in this and
other than some qualms here or there
it was pretty much what i wanted it to
be and yeah it really delivered
and it did more unique things with the
violence than i expected that's one
thing i got really got to give it credit
to and the lore
actually does give it more of the
cultish vibe where you can like
i'd buy merch for this yeah yeah i feel
like it yeah it's stuck it's landing
it's like there are certain ways it
could have been a little bit more than
what it is
but it hit the perfect spot for the
b-movie type of experience i wanted and
then gave me things to appreciate
on top of that especially in like the
sound designs just the choice of
angles the beautiful oh the player the
lighting was gorgeous lighting
striking yeah the music was so well
complete like it was great original
music yeah
absolutely like they really tied it all
together there are certain things that
could have maybe been a little bit more
smooth that are a little bit more
developed but overall i thought this was
like a really solid fun bee movie
yeah it doesn't outstay its welcome
doesn't get annoying or anything like
that like
kudos awesome hell yeah wooly's
wonderland people
what'd you think of the film leave your
thoughts down below hit that like button
check us out on patreon
if you want check out that interview by
the way and uh
last but not least
scuba steve john you always want to
shout him out every month i'm like john
who do you want to do and he goes to the
same four to five
names you're one of those four to five
names it's cause i love you scuba diving
for you i want you to know that i love
you more than most all other patrons
because i play
favorites it's not true scuba steve
you're a good guy
you're a quality human being you're out
there risking your neck
but you know what you bring us joy you
bring us love and support and also
you're a badass graffiti artist and i
would be remiss not to me
let that reference that in a movie with
such cool graffiti all over the walls
so uh if ever you're looking to
return the favor for this shout out make
me a little willie's wondering graffiti
a little nicholas cage graffiti that's
good you
always successfully type back into what
we've reacted to i'm proud of you
dude that's that's just like a thing i
did it you nailed it
you nailed it thanks steve